Es una pregunta interesante.
Obtuvimos resultados interesantes.
El 94 % respondió que no.
(Risas)
No queremos contratar gente aburrida y sin imaginación, ¿no?
El 6 % probablemente no entendió la pregunta.
(Risas)
Pero, pobre de ellos,
quizá sí quieren contratar gente aburrida y sin imaginación.
Pero el 94 % contestó que no. Entonces, ¿por qué lo seguimos haciendo?
Yo creo que es algo bastante simple, que todos nosotros,
hemos sentido en nuestro interior.
Cuando nos contratan para trabajar en una organización,
un club, un estudio jurídico, una escuela, o el tipo de organización que sea,
nadie sube inmediatamente hasta los puesto más altos.
Se comienza en los puestos más bajos.
¿Y qué se hace? Se trabaja.
Precisamente, tienen que trabajar, ¿no es así?
Y si son especialmente buenos en su trabajo, ¿cómo se los recompensa?
Con más trabajo.
Así es, todos Uds. son muy buenos microgestores.
(Risas)
Deben trabajar más y, en poco tiempo, si son buenos en su trabajo,
aún trabajarán un poco más,
pero luego comenzarán a gestionar a otras personas que harán el trabajo.
Y si son muy buenos en eso, ¿qué sigue?
Comenzarán a gestionar a las personas que gestionan a quienes hacen el trabajo.
Y ése es el momento en que empiezan a perder el control
sobre el resultado de su trabajo.
Yo lo experimenté en carne propia.
Comencé una empresa llamada 'Boxed', en mi cochera.
Aquí la ven, sé que no parece mucho.
Se puede ver la lavadora a presión al fondo.
Es el "sueño hecho realidad".
Mi esposa estaba muy orgullosa de mí cuando comencé esto.
Es lo que dijo, que estaba muy orgullosa.
Estoy seguro de que cuando me abrazaba tomaba su teléfono y pensaba:
"Oh, ¿John de Harvard seguirá soltero?".
Al principio fue como un puesto de limonada sin éxito.
Pero luego avanzamos y consideramos que el transporte de productos crecería
y que los bienes de consumo envasados iban a cambiar con el tiempo.
Tomamos estos enormes paquetes que nadie quiere llevarse a casa,
es decir, no dos paquetes de galletas oreo, sino 24 paquetes;
no 24 paquetes de papel higiénico, sino 48 paquetes
y los enviamos al cliente, como haría un almacén,
sólo que ellos no se encargarían del envío.
Eso hicimos, básicamente.
Teníamos una impresora muy lenta
y entonces pensamos: "Esta impresora es superlenta".
"Improvisemos un mensaje que deleite a los clientes en el dorso de las facturas."
Cosas como "hey, sigue sonriendo", "hey, eres genial",
"hey, que disfrutes los Doritos", o "también nos gusta beber Gatorade".
Cosas así.
Así empezamos a acabar con la monotonía en el trabajo,
ya que debíamos empaquetar todas las cajas
y eso era básicamente todo lo que hacíamos 8, 9, 10, 12 horas al día,
sentados en la cochera.
Entonces pasó algo interesante.
Comenzamos a crecer.
Y durante las últimas...
De hecho, 36 meses después
terminamos vendiendo artículos por cientos de millones de dólares,
y crecimos muy, muy rápido.
Pero en ese momento mi función también comenzó a cambiar.
Sí, yo era el CEO en la cochera, y también hacía el resto del trabajo,
pero luego ascendí y comencé a gestionar a las personas que empaquetaban el producto;
y, al poco tiempo, a la gente que gestionaba a las personas
que empaquetaban el producto.
Y ahora incluso gestiono al personal a cargo de los departamentos,
quienes gestionan a las personas
que gestionan a quienes empaquetan el producto.
En ese preciso momento, perdí el control.
Sabía que a los clientes les encantaban estas notas.
Pero yo ya no podía seguir escribiéndolas.
¿Qué hacer entonces?
Voy a enseñarles a los empleados a escribir estas notas:
qué bolígrafo usar, qué color elegir, qué deberían escribir,
que tipografía escoger, cómo configurar los márgenes;
esto tiene que ser así, aquello así.
Y esta intención de motivarlos para acabar con la monotonía
en el lugar de trabajo, rápidamente se volvió microgestión
y la gente comenzó a quejarse con RR. HH.
"Este CEO tiene que darme un respiro; sé cómo escribir una tonta nota."
(Risas)
Y en ese momento nos pareció bien.
Ya que contamos con estas personas geniales y creativas,
dejemos en sus manos la misión de 'deleitar al cliente',
brindémosles las herramientas para hacerlo, es decir, las notas.
Lo que descubrimos fue sorprendente.
Algunos tomaron las notas y comenzaron a dibujar estos pequeños murales en ellas.
Cuando la gente compraba pañales, recibían notas divertidas como esta:
"¡Saluda al bebé por nosotros!".
Y al comprar pañales más grandes recibían la nota:
"Qué rápido crece".
A la gente realmente le gustó.
Pero en esa época también nos descarrilamos un par de veces.
P. ej., había quien escribía únicamente "Grx, grx" en todas las notas,
y yo le comentaba: "Eso es lo que mi jefe solía escribirme,
así que ya no escribamos 'Grx'".
También surgieron respuestas interesantes en el otro extremo.
Algunas personas eran demasiado creativas.
Como expliqué antes, vendemos todo al por mayor:
paquetes enormes de pañales, de papel higiénico,
de Doritos y de galletas Oreo.
También vendemos grandes paquetes de anticonceptivos,
así que...
Esto se está poniendo incómodo.
(Risas)
Vendemos paquetes de 40 preservativos, somos todos adultos, 40 preservativos.
Alguien ordenó cuatro paquetes de 40 preservativos.
(Risas)
Y ésa fue toda la compra: 160 preservativos.
Y el empaquetador pensó: "Ya sé cómo divertir a este cliente".
(Risas)
Este empaquetador escribió:
[Todos quieren a los optimistas]
(Risas)
(Aplausos)
No sabíamos si ascenderlo o despedirlo, pero aún trabaja con nosotros.
"Todos quieren a los optimistas."
En este caso se descarriló un poco y me sentí un poco indeciso al respecto.
Oh, hay un error de tipeo muy feo allí.
Si tan sólo tuviera T, E y D en el escenario
no sería un error de tipeo, ¿no?
(Risas)
(Aplausos)
Les advertí que era malo haciendo bromas así que ahora lo estoy demostrando.
Pero en verdad estaba indeciso.
Y en ese momento comenzamos a hacer cosas
que no eran parte de la misión del negocio,
y los empleados comenzaron a hacerlas mal.
Entonces pensé: "¿Deberíamos dejarlos fracasar?,
¿deberíamos dejar que sigan haciendo esto?".
No lo sé.
No lo sabía en ese momento.
Pero me pregunté: "El fracaso ¿es de verdad algo tan malo?".
No digo que debamos festejar el fracaso.
Muchos en Silicon Valley dicen "Festejemos el fracaso".
No, yo no estoy tan seguro.
En nuestras reuniones nadie dice:
"Ey, Chieh, cómo fracasaste el último trimestre, sigue así, amigo".
Nunca nadie dice eso.
Si son parte de una organización así,
llámenme, quiero participar en esas reuniones.
No creo que nadie celebre el fracaso de forma privada,
pero yo pienso que el fracaso es realmente necesario
para los empleados a largo plazo, para las personas inteligentes e imaginativas
que verdaderamente intentan completar la tarea que están realizando.
Por eso, el fracaso puede considerarse como un paso en el camino hacia el éxito.
Así que si la desventaja de no microgestionar
es este supuesto de que puedes fracasar con más frecuencia,
y si esto no es tan malo, ¿cuál es la ventaja?
Pues bien, descubrimos la ventaja y es muy buena.
Les dimos una tarea a nuestros ingenieros y les explicamos:
"Algunos de nuestros almacenes son muy costosos,
tienen kilómetros de cintas transportadoras.
¿Pueden hacer que sean más eficientes sin tener que gastar millones de dólares?
Así que se pusieron a trabajar.
Esto no es photoshop, él está soldando de verdad.
Construyeron un vehículo de guiado automático.
No les indicamos qué construir ni de qué manera.
El primer prototipo estuvo listo en 90 días.
Funciona con baterías Tesla, tiene cámaras estereoscópicas, sistemas LIDAR.
Básicamente, es lo mismo que la cinta transportadora:
misma eficiencia, menor costo.
Y no nos limitamos a los ingenieros.
A nuestro departamento de marketing les dijimos:
"Hey, comenten esto con los demás, hagan lo correcto".
Una excelente empleada en el equipo de marketing, Nitasha,
una mañana me dijo: "Chieh, ¿qué vamos a hacer con el impuesto rosa?".
Me senté junto a ella y le pregunté:
"Nitasha, ¿qué es el impuesto rosa?".
Ella me contó y es algo muy interesante.
Puede que algunos de Uds. ya lo sepan, en 32 estados de EE. UU.
se cobra un impuesto al lujo por productos para mujeres,
como productos de higiene femeninos.
Los tampones y las toallas sanitarias se venden como artículos de lujo.
Es como si mi esposa me pidiera:
"Cariño, compra unas toallas sanitarias camino a casa",
y yo contestara: "Cielo, ¿sabés qué? La economía no anda muy bien...
Así que nada de artículos de lujo este mes,
pero el próximo mes te conseguiré algunos."
Me quedaría soltero bastante rápido, ¿no?
Lo interesante es que no les indicamos qué hacer.
En colaboración con finanzas, consiguieron una rebaja al impuesto a los consumidores
de todo el país que debemos cobrar injustamente.
Puede que se estén preguntando:
"Pues bien, ¿cuál es la verdadera ventaja de no microgestionar?
Es ésta:
Yo no creé ninguno de estos proyectos, no creé el vehículo,
no ideé la campaña "Repensar el impuesto rosa".
Nada de esto fue idea mía.
Sin embargo, soy yo quien está en el escenario TED llevándose el crédito.
(Risas)
"Este tipo no hace nada y se lleva todo el crédito.
Es un auténtico CEO, de verdad lo es."
(Risas)
Pero la verdad es ésta:
No soy 100 % CEO,
pero ciertamente he aprendido la lección más importante de mi vida
y es esta:
Existe una única solución a la microgestión
y es confiar en los demás.
Gracias.
(Aplausos)